alright hello again everyone so you know
who I am because I've been comparing
away so my name is Ian Oswald I'm coach
at the conference and I'm going to be
talking now on shipping data science
projects so the background of this is
rather than looking at individual
techniques and technologies and machine
learning approaches here I'm trying to
look at the bigger picture how do we as
practicing data scientist successfully
deliver working products of clients and
I'm looking at the business side of this
not the academic side of this although
there are a couple of slides touching on
academic reproducibility later on in the
talk and so so am I so I've been doing
industrialized data science for 15 or so
years I started after my master's degree
late 90s in an AI research company a
French British company five years there
is senior programmer working on the
production ization of alpha to beta
products using AI and getting them into
big corporates and then after that I
left there and started my own
consultancy and that's grown into model
insights which I run with my partner
Chris who's around here somewhere this
weekend and we work on industrialized
data science products somewhere around
natural language processing machine
learning as a particular specialism and
so for 10 years I've been shipping
things that work for clients on a couple
occasions I've nearly ship things and
they haven't worked and we killed the
project and there's been some important
lessons behind that but generally the
reason why it's worked for over a decade
is because the products work that means
I've learned a lot of lessons about how
to make things work successfully how to
de-risk things how to position things
correctly at the beginning so you get
them all the way through to success and
this kind of touches upon what meta was
talking about this morning with a
process in place where model building is
a part of the process but are many other
things around it i'm also an o'reilly
also i plug the booking off I think and
I've been growing this part of the group
growing this pi data meet up and
conference series over the last year
thank you very much for coming i'm
really excited of Aquarius
much in the space of the year so so one
of the interesting questions i think is
simply which kind of project succeed in
the first place so they decide to means
many things to many people the
definition that i tend to use is that a
data scientist is a statistician who
knows more engineering than their
colleagues and a programmer who knows
more stats than their colleagues but it
just means that i'm more on the
engineering side I've got colleagues
were more on the machine learning and
stats side we set them some kind of
continuum so no one person knows
everything of course a huge field but
data scientists describe as being this
wonderful massive thing that solves all
problems using data and big data and
their silly terms are not really very
descriptive so we need I think many ways
are beginning to talk about the kind of
products that work so that we can
identify projects and this short list is
made by looking at things I've worked on
in the last ten years that have worked
and also spotting the projects that
haven't worked and then taking them out
the list so the things that I think work
particularly well for basic areas and
I'm happy to take editions a few fair if
you reckon I've missed something
explaining data so some kind of
visualization that's the obvious start
point for a lot of projects under rated
by anybody who likes doing interesting
stuff but the ability as Karen said
yesterday in his visualization talk the
ability to communicate to the hominid
visual cortex quote from Karen it's
incredibly powerful if you're presenting
results to anyone with money pretty
pictures do the right job so we don't
need clever models who need pretty
pictures that explain what's going on so
the first point for me was underrated
for a long time to me long time to
realize that I should just make nice
diagrams automating a repetitive and
slow processes so there's an awful lot
of value here most of us spend an awful
lot of our time our keynote yesterday
Elena spent spent many months doing
manual curation of optical character
recognized data from scanned pdfs to
make excel spreadsheets so that she
could grow some graphs explaining how
money was moving with lobbying firms I
think it was but the majority of that
task was simply doing the data scanning
and extraction and automating that's
incredibly important and an augmenting
data so in witching search result
making new features for machine learning
this gets you to the next stage where
you can do really interesting stuff and
it's typically what we think about big
data science but those first two steps
are very important and then finally
predicting the future it's all about the
machine learning well it's kind of about
the machine learning because that's just
another step in the process and if you
think I've missed anything off then be
happy to at your feedback so I'll talk
about this in the context of several
examples so I've been working with a
company called elevate direct for the
last year and a half and I'll use them
for a couple of my examples so elevates
are trying to automate contract
recruitment their contract recruiters
who realize that at some point someone
would automate the industry and take
humans out of the most of the loop so
they decided to do it to themselves so
they could get the exit do they hide me
and my group as the internal data
scientists and then we are automating
all that hard messy stuff with the text
so you upload your cv you don't do
anything inside upload your cv we
recognize it pull out all of your messy
text opens and the poorly described
companies where you write one of you
write a royal bank of scotland one of
you rights RBS one of your rights are
BOS and we know that that's the Royal
Bank of Scotland we normalize all of
that and the skills then we can match
your CV to jobs that are in the system
and start to meld them together and the
kind of tools that I've been using
there's a high school [ __ ]
elasticsearch and then pandas
scikit-learn on the rest that's a year
and a half of shipping working services
into this system so that should give you
a bit of context that I can work around
so a slide on visualizing first of all
my best observation so far in ten years
is that most data isn't that interesting
and even if you've got interesting data
it might look interesting to you as
without wearing a scientific hat but
from the business point of view it could
will not be interesting to so probably
what you need is some kind of detective
person such the scientist and also the
human curator so that'll be the an
internal business purse maybe a CTO may
be a CEO someone who knows how to drive
the process if you have those two people
or a CTO that knows both of those roles
and is happy to put the time into this
and they're good enough to pull out the
dirty data and transfer
mix and clean it up and do whatever is
necessary to present it then you have a
really a very powerful pipeline to
explain where what you've got in your
data stores also to figure out what's
missing in your data stores and figure
out what kind of data you have to
collect to tell the right stories I know
that Seaborn that's bottom left has been
mentioned if you're not using Seaborn
but you use map but they definitely look
at seabourne it gives us many more
powerful visualizations in one line so
much less faffing around writing lots of
loose and trying to make maps lot live
look like it's doing the right job it
just makes things a lot easier bouquet
was talking friday and that's getting
quite powerful and HTF compass anyone
using if any of you are using hdf5 so
large matrix data stores gigabytes or
terabytes of matrix data in flat files
with hdf5 the great python support a PDF
compasses of visualizer on top so rather
than pulling it out saying to pandas and
then drawing graphics you can do that
maybe with hdf compass so we've got a
nice set of tools in tableau
commercially to visualize our data
extracting data from binary files is not
often considered to be a worthy task
it's something I've spent a majority of
my time the last ten years doing because
getting the raw data route is absolutely
necessary so that you can begin to do
anything interesting with anything
projects across so for example with the
with the elevated project at the last
year and a half the first nine months I
spent basically cleaning up the
normalizing date and making systems that
would automatically clean up this data
so if I've got hundreds of thousands of
CVS with lots of different spellings of
the Royal Bank of Scotland and twenty
thousand other companies and fifty
thousand skills and all of their
variants in domains like IT that I
understand an oil and gas that I don't
comes out or medical which I really
don't understand how do we automatically
clean that all up denormalize it get
canonical list of companies and skills
as my targets that I can work towards
deal with all the weird text encodings
takes a lot of time and so this is a
something someone coming into this
particular if people coming out of
academia and often surprised to discover
the datasets aren't beautiful and
industry
how many academics are in the room I'm
probably not a couple right he said in
case you haven't spotted it yet
industrial data sets a rubbish normally
I need a lot of work to clean them up so
rather than doing this kind of work by
hand you don't wanna be writing module
rules by hand or as helaina was doing
cleaning up ocr'd output by hand we want
to automate it text rack that's a nice
pison wrapper around the number of tools
which you can probably barely read on
the right hand side that was a
screenshot of their dog page with text
racks you can do OCR you can extract
HTML you can do speech recognition you
can extract from word documents and PDFs
and all sorts often extracts of that
binary data into some some text
representation that's not particularly
brilliant there's mark things up for you
so you have to figure out where in that
text of a person cvr company names and
dates and experience blocks and lists of
references and email addresses nothing
does that for you there are specialized
tools like sovereign that begin through
their their commercial tools and letter
there is one open source project that
will read PDFs of academic research
papers and try to mark them up and then
break out the various sections as a
human would and do that automatically I
forget the name of it anyone know what
I'm talking about offhand anyone doing
research on academic papers there's
certainly an open source tool for this
that's trained with an ml back end which
is quite nice turn it in that's not what
I had in mind sir mine yes I think
content mine is sur- oh my maybe the
contraction so sir mine is something to
CRM I any was searching for if you're
doing that kind of work but this takes a
lot of time and it's a tiny example of
some type I've worked on a couple of
years ago with Karen who spoke yesterday
doing optical character recognition on
phones with photographs of botanical
garden labels so this was in robert
aight gardens kew taking photographs of
these labels using OCR and text clean up
this is all in Python using text react
and psychic image and a few other tools
an open CV putting out as many
characters as possible not terribly
cleanly but then using elasticsearch to
match them to corresponding wiki
your articles so essentially use the
plant label as a kind of a QR code
without applying QR codes into reality
and then even recognize tens of
thousands different plant labels
automatically and then when i was living
in Chile for a little bit we tried this
in the Botanic Gardens in Chile they
have a Latin ified South American
variant of spellings but is that worked
and I was really happy with that no need
to change the way of processing the text
because it's still a human readable text
so the OCR process work just as well
once you've extracted data you have to
start augmenting it to either generate
features for machine learning say or to
presented for visualization or putting
it into search engines so we've got lots
of tools that enable us to do that
DataSift has been mentioned already yeah
so there are a provider or lots of
social data if you want to get lots of
facebook messages and then start to
analyze those you just buy them through
data search that's great an alchemy API
further down they let you do pretty good
sentiment analysis and named entity
recognition it's one of the best
providers that are evaluated so if you
want to find names of people or places
or products then outcome is very good
for that oh it's got a us buyers it's
not terribly greater Europe and it's not
great for many other languages apart
from American English but and there are
other providers coming along you can of
course use lower level tools like an otk
to write your own and build these up
that becomes quite an involved process
it turns out one interesting trend in
the last couple of years is the rise of
open data and connected open data data
set so a few years ago the Wikipedia
data set made available through dbpedia
kind of a triple mark up a faction
Wikipedia pages was pretty weak and had
lots of errors in it now I base a bunch
of the machine learning work that idea
with elevate off of the open data that
comes out of Wikipedia so definitely
have a look around at different open
data sets there are thousands of sets
now which will have links into each
other so you can pull data from one
source at Wikipedia and link it out to
associated sets and build up a free
greatly corpus of things for learning
against I'll do similarity matching
against
here's a side project have right now and
there's two good reasons for mentioning
this so my wife is allergic to the air
she claims she is allergic to the very
air that she breathes and has been for
all of her life so she sneezes a lot
we'd like to diagnose what is causing
this so she's an iphone developer just
recently joined Mozilla so on the left
she's an actress elf where she can
record when she has allergic symptoms so
she's sneezing or she's interacted with
a cat or a dog or smelled flour or she's
taken loratadine so an antihistamine so
we can record the events then on the
right time building up the model using
mostly pandas just taking that raw data
and putting it onto a timeline the black
bar is a poor representation I know the
black bars are 24-hour periods those
blue dots that thick line of blue dog
status sneezes so she sneezes a lot and
then the question is what drives the
sneezing can I use machine learning to
start to look into this I've got a note
of the bottom there that I'm pulling in
her diet data from My Fitness Pal so if
she loves the food that she eats you're
pretty sure that alcohol the night
before which does affect histamine
levels has a knock-on effect the next
day with her propensity to sneeze pollen
in the air that's reported on the BBC
news website and the Met Office and the
benadryl site but isn't clean API so
I'll be scraping that Shore low and then
pollution data that was covered in
yesterday's open air to open London air
talk so there i'm taking pm10 and PM 2.5
particular reports around london and
they're modeling pollution in the air
and this all gets merged in into pandas
due to the time series emerging to give
me a really rich data set which I can do
my machine learning off so this is it
this is fun for two reasons one I'm
hoping some of you might have done this
kind of work before I could give me some
feedback on the projects you've worked
on time series data predictions and the
medical area in general and secondly I
get to do signs on my wife so this is
kind of good fun and I get to do it
because she can write an app and I can
use pandas and then I can draw in which
data sources partly open data partly
scraped partly data were deriving
ourselves and then with a fully open
source tool stack were able to generate
them
well I'm beginning to generate a machine
learn model around this to understand
her allergies and we've got several
friends of hers who have allergies as
well using the app gathering their data
sets so here we're looking at an
approach to a personalized medicine not
via some big study but just because I'm
kind of curious about it I'd like to see
her not sneeze so much and so I not sure
where this goes I hope it actually works
I think it's not a stupid approach but
it's kind of fun that is so easy to do
with the taller that's available to us
so talking of this tooling we had a
tutorial on Friday about pie MC package
I'm pretty sure everyone here knows
about scikit-learn it is the main
machine learning tool in Python and it's
a very large project with a lot of
contributors as anyone in here
contributed to scikit-learn somebody
somebody of Charlotte okay in that case
then that text in black the simplest
thing you can do if you want to
contribute to any open source project
and you have not the time or the
confidence or the inclination to
contribute pose or the docs is to cite
those projects so simply either site
that you use them or even better send
them a testimonial saying that you use
their project because they're a use that
to get funding from academic bodies from
research councils and from numb focus
and other groups so if you simply tell
them that you use their product your
company name against them you help them
that's your easiest contribution to open
source libraries that you can make so I
urge you please to at least try and do
that so I scikit-learn and it's been a
rapid rate of the least recently spark
it learn which wraps up the pie spark
interface so rather than having your
psychic learn data model by on your
laptop and then re-implementing using pi
spark and a slightly different interface
instead of spark it learn on Python 2
and Python 3 you can drive the spark
distributed machine learning toolkit so
it's really nice and roll off tossed
earlier spoke about theano and cafe and
the deep learning research so pythons
very popular for deep learning research
partly because it had great drivers for
GPUs so people could build new tools on
top of the GPU drivers and just put that
stack together this is part of why pison
wins in general I think as a glue
language we have so many tools that blew
so many different bits of the stack
together it's easy to start building new
tools and new domains come along here's
a question for you and I'm after your
feedback on this um it strikes me that
one of the least efficient areas of my
time at the moment is debugging the
models that I build I have strategies
for looking into classification tasks
where I've got my main strength
particularly around text classification
to let binary sparse input input vectors
and for say a binary classification task
that's very different to a regression
task very different to image analysis
and yeah I'm pretty sure that I go
through a similar loop with my
approaches to Diagnostics looking at the
quality of a model and the actual output
of a particular model in the output of a
different model trying to understand
which affected which features which kind
of internals in the model are affecting
the quality of an output and I do this
by hand I pretty sure most of us do this
by hand and pretty sure some of you have
written me the tools or processes to
automate some of this or to at least
remove some of the vagary in your
thinking and if nothing else please come
and tell me I want to find out better
ways of doing this because it feels
really silly that I'm making this up
over 10 years as I go along I think
we're all making this up so there must
be a better way to do this and there
must be some talling we could produce so
I'm really keen to see if we can
generate any new tooling around this
anything that helps to silver
scikit-learn was really not powerful
library about five years ago everyone
kind of laughed at it so yet another
machine learning library who really
cares about it now it's a big tall but
it started with just a couple of clean
implementations of useful algorithms so
what about doing the same for
visualizing the quality of a model and
trying to pull out its internals we
don't get any data Diagnostics either
Sarah logistic regression if you pass in
two features one with huge scale your
mom is a small scaling probably the
second feature gets represented poorly
due to the error services that come out
a beginner may not know this an
experienced a person may what will know
this but may not realize their data is
laid out that way it just tried some new
data it just downloaded some put it into
a model they get an output they're happy
enough what about a decorator we can add
to our psychic lower model
says oh the data should be should be
normalized in Ranger 0 and 1 it should
be Gaussian these so we don't expect any
strong correlations between our features
just some way of marking up how we
should describe our data to think about
it a slightly higher level I don't think
I'm crazy for suggesting this maybe some
of you have thoughts as to why this is a
better idea all have done this so I'd
love your feedback so yet your hard-won
knowledge please help me make new debug
tools and so it's not it's not terrible
weaned on Friday we had a nice tutorial
from chicken and Elena from Cambridge
talking about representing the the
decision boundaries safe to features and
we can go to three features we can't
really go to full features under a
thousand features of course but if
you've got two dominant features we can
begin to pull this apart perhaps so we
get something out and then the image in
the background say with a decision tree
on ensemble of decision trees like a
random forest you can pull apart 5 10 20
features to begin to look at them and
then I stole the Roloffs image from the
last talk beginning to look at
diagnosing deep deep chatter training
networks he's got says he had some nice
slides looking at what the deep belief
networks are doing at different areas
and then how their training performance
varies and strategies for combating Paul
fitting so there's clearly thinking
about this but I haven't found a book
talking about this so yeah any of your
knowledge please please play it for so I
want to hear it so right now we've
looked at ways to build up successful
projects and this serious problem I
think we have with diagnosing how our
machine learning systems aren't working
now let's look at pushing out to
production so delivery apply the KISS
principle and just keep it simple and
that's the biggest thing when I was
speaking with the academics I was a
teaching PhDs a couple of weeks ago in
Denmark I was invited to speak to
faculty and we've got to talk about
reproducibility of cover in a minute and
there I thought it was important to make
the point that in industry with
typically not if you're not in a
benchmark you're not publishing the best
results you want a good enough result to
solve your business problem so you can
effectively move forward because you've
got million problems to solve so debug
ability it's 3am is where one of the key
I think the more complex the model the
less likely the CTO is to understand
what goes wrong when the system turns
off so you don't want anything to be
overly complex and I like Watson wats
idea with the cult of the imperfect so
what's and watch with it was one of the
developers of radar during world war two
and he'd say that the the best system
are not going to have that is never
going to turn up the second-best system
we could have that but it will take too
long third base system we're going to
get there we'll have that one and this
idea of just it's good enough we'll just
work with that if that was good enough
to develop radar in world war two that's
good enough for me the living systems to
my crimes unless we're doing a benchmark
but that's that's a less likely
eventualities for a client and so that
last point dumb models and clean data
beat most other combinations definitely
more data can help in the right kind of
scenario and and dirty data if you've
got lots of it maybe you can get quite a
long way with that but in my experience
feature engineering a lots of data
cleanup so that you're putting good
stuff into a model in the first place
probably a dumb model like logistic
regression works pretty damn well and
it's easy to diagnose so always strive
first simplicity put more time in to
make it as simple as possible afterwards
and then there are various ways to kill
a project so I interviewed the number of
CTOs over the last year to find out what
the biggest reasons they've seen for a
project dying around for a data science
project dying the number one reason was
simply missing data so either lots of
data but it was the wrong stuff so they
logged the wrong stuff or too many gaps
or they gathered almost all of the right
data for missing a key feature but for
whatever reason there wasn't the right
data available and the simple advice
that comes out of that is this log
everything storage is fairly cheap if
you're logging fraction of a second
sensor data there maybe there's a large
storage cost maybe that's not quite the
right strategy but for most companies
they don't have a big data problem so
storing gigabytes worth the data just
fits on a hard drive it's really easy so
just log all the pertinent stuff and a
company like a segment io will take all
of your different feeds of data in they
look after it and they can join it to
external data sources for you from other
so that can simplify a whole part of
that data and storage and analysis
pipeline or just put it into manga I
mean it I don't care where it goes but
just don't lose the damn data if you're
storing lots of data it will go wrong he
will miss things they will be lies in
their processes will log the wrong stuff
and and if you are dealing with past
eight or so data someone else is giving
you it will contain lies it will not be
as clean as anyone thinks it is so
unique data quality reports this is one
of my biggest time sinks in the last
year and a half and it's probably been
one of my biggest times things over ten
years so inheriting other data and
looking new tech to and then it just
it's the wrong stuff so be very clear
that you need to have some kind of
reporting in there to get high quality
data out and it's definitely worth
noting that our d is not the same as an
engineering process if you're the sole
researcher in an engineering group and
the engineering group hasn't had a PhD
researcher in there then all of a sudden
the the working requirement changes a
lot it's totally okay to push back and
just say now hang on this is not an
agile engineering process where I know
what I'm going to deliver how long it
might take in that in some kind of
estimation game and then I'm going to
deliver it this is not on d process this
will be iterative they will be failure
we're going to learn from the failure
and this is part of the protesters
totally okay there's a new tool decide i
think that's data scientists against
dirty data one guy taking an art or
moving it into the python world so i
just mentioned that as part of your
you're missing and poor quality data you
use decorators for data frank analysis
to put something strange on your data
frame this feels like a good idea maybe
this is worth extending so for
deployment i've used the ipython
notebook for internal deployments i'm
guessing some of you may not seen the
interactive feature so that interact
function to give it a function you give
it some limits on a variable so that
variable F takes 16 to 18 in point one
increments it gives you a slider bar or
a drop-down our text box or a button and
then if you are you slide around in your
ipython notebook it will update the
plots that you're generating it's
supremely useful for demonstrating
things internally to colleagues
particularly giving them a mental model
as to how you change some variables and
the outputs change that's just really
good for getting a deep model inside
your head as to how some
complex process works but you can't put
that on the web because that exposes
your entire Python interpreter in
whatever environment is running to the
web so you could just type OS system RM
star that will be a bad thing totally
ipython notebook models onto the web and
I've torn in a second guess that would
do for that the tool that you might want
to use is spire so its spire it's a bit
like our shiny that was mentioned in a
talk earlier and you can use Panthers
data frames and tabs and buttons and
sliders and then mount your models on a
web service that only exposes a thin
connection so it's a very secure way to
put models out there in a prototype way
personally I use flask in a micro
service so flask is a a restful api at
all it's like a lightweight Django so in
a couple of lines i can write to get and
put requests which let me take requests
and take data and then query my numpy
models on my side hi models on my
circular models and then return some
json as a result so it's a really
powerful way of packaging up some of
this some of these tools and I think
docker which gets us towards a
reproducible environment I could run a
doctor machine here with a virtual box
inside it and I can deploy that to
Amazon ec2 or 20 or to a colleague's
machine and I get exactly the same
environment to run my code in a
reproducible way I think that's aware of
the future it's not solid right now but
it's so experimenting on that in elevate
that's going to an interesting tool in
the next six months with flask you can
do swagger documentation so a couple of
decorators on your flask model and it
will expose a web page which has all of
your API endpoints documented and a text
entry box you can copy in your query the
same query you'd send from your other
language over the wire to the micro
service hit the try it out button and it
will query your API and then take the
JSON response and display below so you
can diagnose it this means you can put
examples in the web page which is your
API tour actual API it's not set for
documentation it adjust the API so
that's a very nice powerful way to
document your running models so when I
spoke with the faculty and Emma couple
of weeks ago and we had a quick chat
about reproducibility I was curious
about the rise of the
is in people noticing that many research
studies can't be reproduced that's bad
right that's a waste of money and a
waste of people thinking they found
something significant that maybe it's
not significant I suspect that at some
point someone is going to say only there
was a domain where every time you ran
this thing it ran exactly the same I bet
they figured out how this
reproducibility malarkey works and
someone's going to go computer science
right these computers do the same thing
it runs the same every time let's go to
the computer scientists and the data
scientists who are there and figure out
how they have these fully reproducible
systems and then people are going to
come to us and we going to go yeah kind
of work some other time on my machine
and it's not quite the same as having a
fully deployed reproducible system that
runs anyway right but we need we are
mean we are solving this problem many
academics aren't worrying about this yet
but nature is beginning to require
reproducible work before they publish
publish articles so it's going to become
bigger into that domain and it's going
to become more more required in our
domain as well particularly publishing
say scikit-learn you can fully reproduce
all of our test suite on any machine
that's a nice example if we produce
ability in the face of randomness so
they're always doing this but I must
become a more important thing as we go
and the ipython notebook was in featured
in nature as a way of using reproducible
computing cuzzo notebooks and data
mounted on ec2 instance and then that
little box down the bottom there so
that's the the article that describes to
regular readers of nature why you should
use Python for reproducible science that
was quite a strong statement so I'm
going to wrap up with a couple of slides
and Python deployments and if you're not
making modules in your code already you
should be making modules so that's sir
that means you can just do a python set
up the pie install on the module and
have it run on your machine or your ec2
your machine or your colleagues machine
so you conversion edge and you can
document it and distribute it if you
don't know about Python set up top I
develop needed Tony in the room I Tony
not totally yes Tony told me two years
ago about Python set up the pie develop
it means you haven't got to install it
inside your site packages instead it in
your site packages you get a symlink
back to you
directory so it looks like a real
package and you can then packaged it up
and distribute it but you develop it
just locally like you're developing it
anyway that's supremely useful and you
want unit tests and coverage if you
haven't done this kind of thing before
I've got a template so my get Harvey
Oswald Python template with config
there's a configuration system in their
unit tests in a module format with some
documentation and logging setup for
standard out help so if you want a
template to work off go and borrow that
and if you want to look more into this
kind of thing I'd suggest looking at the
12 factor app it's a nice write-up by
another company I think to do with
Heroku looking at ways of producing
reproducible engineered systems and
Karen's book noted there when Karen's
book he's talking about publishing your
web service or Jason providing web
service for visualization on the web so
he has a chapter covering some of this
kind of deployment scenario so we're
still writing that book but it's worth
keeping an eye on that in the future I'm
not going to cover all of these anyone
coming into the industry I knew you
might think that we have lots of
standards to make things easy some
things are never standard mysql has full
unicode support except that by default
it's three bite not four bytes so you
can't get most of the funny characters
into it that's ridiculous you discover
that when you have question marks and
all of your data that's very painful
because then you have to just delete it
and start again there is a utf-8 for
pipe representation you have to enable
that yourself when you discovered it
after the fact javascript months are
zero base not one base like in most
other languages so if the minus one date
times everyone thinks they've spotted a
new way to represent the daytime so we
have n plus one daytime representations
just use iso 8601 fully qualified long
string or second since some well-known
epoch no they're about eight epochs out
there so if i take the data from my
wife's iphone apple use 2001 as their
epoch not the unix 1970 epoch CP 1252
encoded text is very common on Windows
platforms Excel by default will try very
hard to only give you windows and coding
not utf-8 so that monkeys up a bunch of
characters better pain [ __ ] DB x helped
by default it's really unhelpful no
timeout cursor true that's a useful
switch to know so it's a bunch of stuff
further that you will discover is broken
these things will always be broken
stackoverflow is your friend here
generally I suggest avoiding big data if
you've got big data you know if you've
got petabytes of data and you want to
resiliency or redundancy or you just
genuinely have a huge amount of nature
to query to find you've got a big data
problem most people have a problem that
may fit on a hard drive but not in their
RAM and they begin to think maybe this
is big data it's not it may be medium
data it fits in a hard drive maybe had
some too hard drives you probably don't
need a cluster a cluster probably means
you get really excited for a month and
then you employ somebody else to sit I
even run the damn thing this is
inefficient on a waste of time if you
write multiprocessing code say on a
laptop with four cores and then you go
and rent a 32 core machine on amazon
with two fifty gigabytes of ram it'll
cost you three bucks an hour it's really
cheap so you can just make your model
locally with a subset of your data
upload the real big data into amazon
easy to rent a big machine run exactly
the same code in parallel so these here
are random forest models in scikit-learn
fully exploiting the large machine and
then you can get your completed model
savers a pic or download it and then
you've gotta finish model trend on a
very large data set without the
requirement for having a cluster and a
person to run cluster and there's a
relatively new project x-ray and desk
but I mentioned at the bottom there
that's four out of core labeled a raise
so data that's typically around which
fits on a hard drive that's a medium
data package ER that lets you run
through your data without having to go
to say to a spark solution so I'm
interested in hearing your dirty data
stories i'm beginning to automate some
of this some certainly collecting tools
to let me automate this because i'm so
bored of having to fix with the state to
myself it's such a waste of my time i
just i don't want to do it anymore so
tell me what what bothers you about your
data because i am collecting the stories
i want to use cases and I beginning to
write tools that fix some of these
things definitely keep it simple just
strive for simplicity
separately I'm just going to plug my PI
data meet up again come and share your
war stories and your projects the
monthly meetup we run in London so 1600
people it's a huge user group and all
that note that slightly silly quote
there I'm not trying to be up my own
bottom here part of the reason why I
build the group is because it's way
easier to solve my problems if I can go
into a room with 200 people find the
three people have solved this thing
before just ask them how I do it that
makes my life easy so there's a hell of
a benefit towards coming to one of these
meetups and there's being part of the
community because it makes your life
easier you get to you get to get past
the boring questions far quicker and
then get on to the more interesting
stuff so I definitely encourage you to
come along and on that Pope we're a
couple of minutes or nonfat lunch is
almost starting so I'm going to wrap up
there and I'm going to suggest they've
got any questions come and talk to me
off because there's no queue for the
food right thank you very much